iPads have dominated the tablet game for
over a decade now but with the new
surface pro X of things about to change
what's going on guys my name is David
homage and welcome back to the channel
today we're going to be comparing
Microsoft's latest product the surface
pro X against Apple's flagship device
that iPad pro 12 point 9 inch display
you guys seem to enjoy last week's video
quite a lot so I'm gonna stick to the
same informative script that I used last
time with only a little bit of personal
opinion thrown in here and there from
user experience the surface pro X starts
from 1699 AUD or 1170 USD whilst the
iPad pro starts from 1749 Australian or
1200 USD I'm using the price of the
cellular version because the surface pro
X only comes with the cellular version
neither device comes standard with a
stylist or a keyboard or any other
accessories for that matter so this
price is just for the raw tablet even
though the surface pro X is cheaper than
the iPad pro Apple does offer you a non
cellular version which comes in at about
1500 Australian so they fund this simple
fact that you can get it cheaper whereas
you can't get the surface pro X cheaper
I'm awarding the price category to Apple
let's talk about tech specs the surface
pro X comes only in the color black
which is actually my preference so
that's pretty good for me it does come
with eight gigabytes of RAM and a
removable 128 gigabyte SSD storage on
top of that you also get Microsoft's
proprietary sq1 chip that doesn't really
mean anything to anybody until we start
measuring it against other competitors
on the market when we take a look at
Geekbench it gets a single core score of
725 whilst against a multi-core score of
2821 the iPad pro on the other hand
comes in two options space grey and
silver if you've had these device before
there isn't too much of an option here
it is just kind of like a light silver
and a dark silver it isn't that black
by contrast it has an a 12x Bionic Apple
chip four gigabytes of RAM and starts
from sixty four gigabytes of storage
however the iPad pro does significantly
better than the surface pro X in
Geekbench scores it gets a single core
score of 1117 and a multi-core score of
four thousand six hundred and sixty two
so this is almost double with the
performance of the surface pro x with
half the ram speed this is all thanks to
the intelligent a 12x Bionic chip inside
the iPad pro on paper the iPad pro is a
much lesser device however when you take
it out into the real world and start
doing some testing like we've done on
Geekbench you find out that it actually
is a better device and the second point
goes to the iPad pro again it's not
looking too good for the surface pro X
at this point in time charging and
battery life the surface pro X has a
theoretical 13 hour battery life and is
supposed 0 200% charge time in under 2
hours whilst iPad pro gets a
significantly less 8 hour runtime and a
two-and-a-half hour charge time it's
impacted again here by the fact that it
doesn't come with an 18 watt charger
straight out of the box if you want to
get this two-and-a-half hour fast charge
you have to go out and buy this extra
plug some very poor stats from Apple
here but a much-needed point for the
surface pro X ports and accessories
surface pro X gives you two USB C ports
which are actually usable because it is
running Windows 10 it also gives you the
nano SIM slot tray for any LTE 4G
compatible SIM card the iPad pro only
gives you one USB C slot which is only
kind of usable for things that are
compatible with iOS operating system it
also does give you that nano SIM card
tray for any for G LTE connect ability
now I'm gonna read the rest of these
accessories off my iPad here because
there's a lot of numbers to remember for
you guys and I think it's better if I
get them right
time so the surface pro X keyboard and
pen bundle comes in at 429 Australian
dollars or 295 us if you want the pen on
its own it's gonna cost you two hundred
and thirty-five Australian dollars or a
hundred and sixty one US dollars that's
pretty steep for just the pen itself a
little extra win here is you can buy the
surface mouse along with it eighty
Australian dollars or fifty five us this
isn't something you can use on an iPad
natively without some additional
accessories last but not least you can
also get the surface dock which gives
you a couple extra potential uses with
the surface pro X it gives you a few
extra USB ports and lets you connect it
to a display so you can run it like a
normal computer that will set you back
another 300 Australian or 200 US apple
on the other hand doesn't offer you a
keyboard pencil bundle it separates
these two into two different price
categories so if you want the iPad
pencil 2 which is only compatible with
the iPad pro it's going to set you back
200 astray llion dollars or a hundred
and thirty five US dollars the smart
Keyboard on top of that is going to be
another 299 Australian or 200 American
it offers a bunch of different
connectors and adapters that you can use
with this single USB port which is not
really relevant for most people so I'm
going to skip over most of that but more
importantly it offers Apple TV which
gives you the wireless compatibility
that you can kind of use it like a
desktop if you wanted to but more
prominently just screen mirroring this
will set you back 280 Australian dollars
or a hundred and ninety USD so overall
in the ports and accessories category
I'm gonna give this one to Microsoft for
the sheer versatility it offers with its
variety of ports and its variety of
accessories the design category design
is a bit more of a personal opinion here
everybody's gonna have their say about
what they think is a better looking
device and a better functioning device I
personally like the look the square boxy
modern look of the iPad pro over the
surface pro X however I do like the
kickstand that the surface pro offers
straight in the body
and you don't need to have a cover over
the top to use it as kind of a little
stand while you're watching TV or typing
notes on top of the design Apple offers
a much better camera setup and a much
better screen respectively you get 600
nits out of an iPad pro whereas you only
get 450 from a surface Pro X as we all
know it offers the Retina screen display
which is miles ahead of anybody else in
the market right now in 2019 so overall
my design category points are going to
the iPad pro so what's the verdict
I think it's glaringly obvious that the
iPad has so many more features over the
surface pro X when it comes to a tablet
battle if this was more of a versatile
laptop battle that's kind of a
two-in-one then yes definitely the
surface pro X would be winning here but
because this is a tablet specific battle
iPad and Apple have mastered this over
the last 10 or so years that they've
been able to fine-tune it every single
year with every single release that's
why I'm giving the crown to the iPad pro
that's all for me guys thank you so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed the
video if you did make sure you smash
that subscribe button for the first time
in 2020 and as always I'll see you next
Monday